MAN: What's wrong, Sara? WOMAN: The guy I have a crush on doesn't like me.
Maybe you should just listen to some sad music and get over it.
*indie rock music*
LYRICS: Then put on a sad song and just sing along.
In which case, just disregard that previous verse and put on some Taylor Swift or Katy Perry.
LYRICS: I can't stop thinking 'bout you but I gotta live without you. You're just a mystery and not worth solving over me.
LYRICS: I'm not gonna let this crush just crush me.  I'm just gonna run 'cause you don't love me.
Nice dance moves.
LYRICS: You don't own me. I'm not gonna let this crush just crush me. I'm just gonna run 'cause you don't love me.
LYRICS: I'm not gonna let this crush just crush me. You don't know me, you don't own me.
LYRICS: I'm not gonna let this crush just crush me. I'm just gonna run 'cause you don't love me. I'm not gonna let this crush just crush me. You don't know me, you don't own me.